[Musique]
les collections botanique de mascarin
sont le cadre idéal pour les sept
collèges participant à l'opération land
art
alors là c'est une performance c'est à
dire que les les personnages vont être
classés dans le jardin botanique
ils ont choisi des paysages en fonction
de leurs personnages donc ça a un sens
derniers préparatifs avant le début de
cette performance artistique
ces jeunes viennent de cilaos et leurs
costumes porte bien des messages
pourquoi ton costume la nature et la
nature la nature et comment si l'os elle
est morte il est éternel
avec une subvention transport et une
aide au fonctionnement de ces ateliers
le département encourage cette
pluridisciplinarité facteur
d'épanouissement
[Applaudissements]
on est en synergie entre d'abord relais
les collèges qui sont la responsabilité
aussi du département la culture
l'éducation
tout cela
l'environnement eh ben c'est une des
compétences du département et nous
entendons me fierais que de faire en
sorte que tous ces éléments se
regroupent pour donner ce spectacle même
si c'est pour un petit instant qui se
posent la question vraiment de leur
rapport à leur contexte et ne pas vivre
dans le contexte sans ce en avançant
comme ça en saison que en se posant
aucune question
tout cela était éphémère mais le contact
des élèves avec leur nature a peut-être
fait évoluer le regard
[Musique]